cómo entender entonces esta relación
entre marco y bailén y qué podría pasar
si majo gana en los próximos cinco años
entre eeuu y francia y quiero
preguntarle esto adoptan
bueno en cuanto a
en cuanto a las relaciones con eeuu
pues tengo entendido que macro
intento hizo y veamos partes mientras
esta crisis que usted está de que está
hablando intentaron de de calmar las
cosas y de acercarse y obvio pues lo que
se puede verlo hoy en día es que eso es
estos esfuerzos
funcionaron y que hoy
francia intenta hacer bastante cerca de
eeuu pues históricamente siempre durante
muchos años ha sido un partidario cerca
y entonces yo dudo mucho que que macrón
quisiera es alejarse de eeuu